I'm joined by Dominic McGregor of social
change the way I think you can only
really know someone is what they consume
on the internet between the hours of
11:30 and 12:30 when no one else is
around
so you're another year sober now how
long is it now - enough yes two years
nine months I've gotten from 23 to 26 so
when you mentioned that you don't drink
- 26 year old they get it mmm so when
you do - 23 year olds they get it a bit
less there's no situation where I feel
like I'd ever need to drink it's the
same wave in fact if we were sat here
talking my cocaine and I'm no gonna do
cocaine again you won't question me if
you're drinking especially heavily
you'll be less picky about your social
engagements because you know that if
you've got [ __ ] or boring friends or
you've got to go to some party that you
probably don't want to go to anyway and
it doesn't really matter cuz you can
just sedate the boredom by getting
lashed like if you want to go out and
drink that is fine but you have to
concede that that drink is either at the
best keeping your life the same length
or making it shorter every night out and
every drink that you have is bringing
you closer to death and that's a fact
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by Dominic McGregor of social
chain thing how are you man good thank
you how are you very good
welcome to my studio yes nice yes it's
really lovely
[Laughter]
it's been almost exactly a year since we
sat down yeah yeah yeah about a year in
two weeks yeah almost exactly going on
how have you been last year yeah I've
been being really good
I said message deliver week because I
was in the gym and a lovely woman called
Tracy said to me I heard you I heard you
on a podcast
she's like the PT there I've never seen
her she was beaten or something and
she's that ah I'm well which one and jar
and modern wisdom is a-ok and she's like
since since I've listed that podcast
I've stopped drinking I've done it I've
done six months and my whole life
changed I was up there like I remember
why I talk about all this stuff right
yeah and I was I'm so happy I'm so happy
for you and she was really lovely had a
nice conversation and then literally
that was nice I was walking out the gym
I pick my phone up i text you and said
look gotta go again go again it's been
it's been a year because it came up on
my time memory memories on Facebook um
on everyone checks that every single
morning what was I doing six years ago
oh my god delete that seven years ago
delete that that's all it is isn't it
it's just a way of moving the window of
whatever you've got going on in your
life just like this yeah there's nothing
after whatever period you're pretty and
in seven years time you go oh my god I
was doing this today like yeah rid of
that so some of the smoothies comments
the most cringe things that I work on my
if if you don't look at your memories
look at them and just think who was I
yeah you're different person right
but yes you get about one doing today no
we're not however later on we are going
to look at our suggested videos on
YouTube you want to explain what you
think about suggested videos on YouTube
and how they're a window into someone's
soul so yeah everything everything
obviously we social channel working
social media so we do a lot of paid
social advertisement so we know we kind
of hype offers
that we know people better than
themselves but we definitely know we
know people better than their spouses or
their best friends know people because
like you just the things you do on you
phone in the social media that gets
stored but no one you never tell people
that you never sit there and be like oh
last night I did this or that's night I
watch that or I really like this picture
so we went home to York and I've talked
to my friends and I was just tell my
coming summer stuff that you can do on
social media now because they are
working like very traditional Wells and
I said you know all our side like
between it all here we work we know each
other what we're gonna be in friends for
for 15 years now we don't really know
each other okay know what you mean is
like well the way I think you can only
really know someone are they actually
the easiest way to really know someone
is what they consume on the internet
between the hours of 11:30 and 12:30
when no one else is around that's who
you are
that someone is you put a person it cuts
so deep that history of what you've
watched you know YouTube internet
whatever you want to look at it is who
you are as a person let's go guys that's
your wit that's your weird thing and
that's that's that says more like I'll
say more about me and more about Chris
then we could sit here and say in our
own conversation okay mine are really
boring they're actually uh you've been
like well into brexit and and
researching that reason is it just a lot
of political stuff number one good
Empire how Britain made the modern world
there we go
that's pretty normal pretty normal
mmm-hmm number one for me little figure
Littlefinger is the protagonist Game of
Thrones ending breaking news to reason
maze breaks it deal rejected I'll get a
brace on there yeah yep I scroll through
a couple and
[Music]
for Game of Thrones Season eight teaser
White Walkers yep Game of Thrones in
there mm-hmm nothing nothing to about
how China's rise will change the world I
think I've seen that one as well I've
got some Jordan Peterson
yep Joe Rogan on leaving Netherland is
it just an image of him in Michael
Jackson she's a bit bizarre Graham
Hancock ancient advanced technology
technologies of the gods Graham Hancock
say could an Egyptologist now I really
don't know how this is on there so Gary
Gary Vee Gary Vee archives is on there
we've got a big Gary Vee fan in the
house I could not be further from the
truth
about Gary Vee now Gary if you're
listening actually just please please
don't please don't listen man because
anyone who does a collaboration with
k-swiss to put the words hustle and
grind on the bottom of shoes needs to
get in the sea like Gary is I totally
get why he is a seductive personality
for people that this kind of go get a
21st century thing and American you in
yes yeah yeah it's a very very kind of
Americanized make it on your own type
approach which you know for some people
that might be what they want but there's
a few things that Gary's not going to be
able to get around and one of them is
anyone who is listening will know
Matthew Walker on Joe Rogan number 11 or
nine why we sleep if you great podcast
unbelievable podcast will be linked in
the show notes below if you haven't
watched it you need to watch it it will
change your life I watch it about a year
ago and it changed mine it's the only
podcast which I've listened to its let
me say try to sleep but that was like
out of desire and I've always loved
punchlines away you know before we
started so before we've come on we've
like nerd it out about Game of Thrones
and Warhammer and all this stuff and
I've had too much caffeine and now we're
just going to bounce between different
things that make us seem less and less
cool well that's that's fine but yeah
man like that Gary Vee thing like
you can't get around the fact Gary if
you're having four hours sleep a night
you're gonna die early mmm like it
you're just going to die sooner that
it's a it's a fact he yeah I I don't
agree with I don't agree with a lot of
things he says I don't grieve with him
but I think he's you know credit he's
found the niche and a demographic of
individuals who follow him mm-hmm
you know bit preachy but when we look at
the world now we're all trying to find
some kind of like way to belong and if
people find peace in themselves with
supporting him and his attitude and they
get progressed their life I don't know
do I agree with that
well it's whether or not I try and find
some injustice to say nice something
nice about Gary Vaynerchuk
I mean you've managed to find one more
thing than I can so but yeah man like I
had to dance around it for a bit you are
you are right like he if he is giving
people some form of a sense of I can go
and do this this is that I have the
capacity to work hard and achieve things
then great
my concern is whether or not people one
of the problems with lumbering lumbering
people with the sole duty of making
themselves successful means that you
completely remove any connection to the
bigger picture yeah like your failings
and your successes are purely at the
behest of your feet and you're like well
hang on that means that anything that I
do or don't do is is my own fault oh
[ __ ] hell there's like an awful lot
of randomness in the world and an
awesome awful lot of look like you you
were a perfect avatar for someone who is
right place right time right skill set
mm-hmm yeah I think he yeah he the net
the net impact it will have although
I'll be negative because people will
criticize themselves because they will
put the hours in they will put the no
sleeping they put the grind in this dog
anywhere and though they're gonna die
early not burn out but if there's one
person who's taken his advice and
actually you know
changed life and then because of him
done something meaningful
hmm that's probably one you are trying
to nuts and that's hybrid everything I'm
about to try and I've got to try and
have that like balance bones for you
well you're at seoeon he so you know you
need to be diplomatic with everything
that you did um so you're another year
sober now how long is it now - enough
yours are we on yeah - - when is she lie
I'm very much so 2 years 9 months well
yes the second this year is like like
literally this year it's just been that
way is that not it's a weird one because
now isn't it I'm at a point where I
don't remember
hmm I really don't remember what it was
like to drink mm-hmm so I'm so past it
now that like I'm just beyond it is it's
it's really hard for me to talk about it
now because I just don't recall the
feeling like a different person yeah
yeah and again like said I was back home
in a week weekend and one of the guys
who was two years both me from school
was there and he said that he's doing
gonna do a year sober because of health
because of things he's seen and
obviously he said I was big influence on
it and I said to him that you don't I
think I said last time you don't see an
impasse until six months it's like the
whole dry January bills like you don't
you don't see a difference in this that
the three weeks whatever you do in
January you won't see it you know for me
the difference like I saw in the first
year and then in the second year is
completely nominal to what I'm feeling
now which is bizarre cos at the time
you're actually like oh my god this is
world-changing and then you in a year
and a half girls
that's nothing I know so really this is
like an exponential growth in yourself
and obviously the start is very rapid
because this is dramatic changes but you
get to a point now where like life isn't
like it's actually gonna sound a bit
weird but people who need to find things
like meditation of other aspects to find
peace and who search that kind of like
inner self yeah like I don't feel like I
need to do any of that because I've
already got it
I've got the balance in myself at the
motor already I don't I can I can just I
can just be rather than having to like
subscribe to like quick fixes or other
things to try and like focus on relaxer
so I'm just like in a complete state of
okay nurse hmm I wonder how long that
equanimity will continue with the
sobriety because I do think that a lot
of that will be due to contrast mm-hmm I
think definitely even though you're not
potentially able to remember the
specific sensation of whites like to be
drunk or hungover the second-order self
referential thoughts will still probably
be there like pre-pre front and Sun yeah
it's all it's all relative yeah so
you'll still be just like in this weird
holy heaven of God like I have so much
[ __ ] timeout so much [ __ ] money
I'm able to have so many more calories
like fantastic that's part of it
yeah I wish I went out I like to go I
went outside the night about 3:00 in the
morning
mm-hmm all right we should sell it you
know if you're drinking the late night
you know I'm not drinking late finish
sober late finish and III I've been ill
since then it's all relative but like
I'm still going out but I'm feeling
worse yeah it's like my but what I have
learnt this year is that drinking does
build a sight a slight bit of resilience
within yourself so I am Moss when I over
exercise I'm more susceptible to illness
100 something and I've got issues with
my girl which I need to manage because
taking alcohol out means that you grow
bad bacteria so true
yeah alcohol would yeah clean it out to
every alcohol cleans you out obviously
like a nominal aspect yeah like you you
you create a culture in your gut which
allows you to Harbor negative bacteria
okay because you're not putting any
toxins in there to to rid them here yeah
yeah so you've got like this thing that
you you know you your body is such a
wonderful thing and that everything is
in balance and when you do reach
homeostasis eventually yeah exactly and
that's that's the point now this year
I've been I've been like discovering is
like Oh a thing that you got to manage
there's always meant to manage so it's
been a bit again like must I've been
focusing on my sleep so when I go out
till 3:00 o'clock my immune systems like
what you're doing hmm I get much better
they honestly is is if you break the
routine it really does hum it really
does dumb it damage me so in that in
that
since like I think that you know alcohol
has does build resilience but you can
but resilience of always so it's but
it's been it's been a fun pet has been a
fantastic journey like I'm confident now
that I'm never gonna drink and like okay
I have a whole Heidi it's completely
gone from so this was something that I
like to touch on one of the last
questions I asked see the last time we
sat down was something that I'd been
pondering for a while about people who
choose to go sober to get themselves
around either substance dependency or an
more habitual dependency on the
situation and on on the feelings that
come from that and that there's a I
think there's an argument to be made
that going completely sober still allows
the substance to have some degree of
control over you but a reintroduction of
it on your terms is the ultimate
completion mm-hm
and you said at the time that your
feelings were you weren't going to drink
for the foreseeable future for as long
as you could see yeah one of the reasons
being a fear about potential relapse and
also just that he didn't want the
downstream effect of drinking . yep
where are you at now with that so the
way i think about it now is that my
problem never was the drinking but my
the problem the the drinking was a side
effect of what was like inherently wrong
with me
so it was an escape mechanism so i would
turn to that when I needed to funnel my
energy and anxieties and situation and
escape it so I can now deal with that
feeling elsewhere so I can deal with it
free going for a walk or I can deal with
it will just you know having twenty
minutes of silence to myself and kind of
going processing it and getting out my
system so I don't need the to turn to
alcohol to solve that problem anymore
and also because it's detrimental when
you turn to alcohol and use it to solve
their problems so I don't I don't need
it
what for i which is it before so then it
becomes a company
then it becomes a complete question over
health and lifestyle choices because
it's not dependent on him or you're not
you know you know a substance abuser but
you make a choice that why do I need to
bring that back into my life and if you
could I got things at last time if I can
ever find a reason why I need to be like
it's my life I will
mm-hm but I can't right now right now
and I like a cop foresee situation where
I never need to bring back into life I
just I can't there's no isn't there's no
I could do every I said I'd do
everything I want I can go out I can
spend time with friends I can go to the
pub like there's nothing there's no
situation where I feel like I'd ever
need to drink and it's just like the
same wave in fact if we were sat here
talking like okay and I said no I'm
gonna do cocaine again you even question
me yeah so I did a I did a podcast with
Edie Latimer who is a very very clever
guy again sings from the sobriety hymn
sheet a little bit more I think he's
maybe six years sober now yeah and
released this podcast on he's a New
Year's Day this year and his birthday
came up shortly after wished him happy
birthday inside hey man I loved loved
speaking to you about this and I linked
him to our last chat loads of resonation
width as well and he said this line in
it man
[ __ ] hell it just hit me so hard in
the fields and he said alcohol is the
only drug where if you don't do it
people assume you have a problem yeah
yeah like no one's going up to you and
going
man why not taking heroin today yeah
like why are you not like sniffing a big
a big fat line on a morning or like
after work or whatever you like but with
alcohol actually someone very clever and
contrarian on Twitter piped up and said
coffee
nice it's a fiends probably to say yeah
what you don't drink coffee like that's
the only one but then maybe 50 years ago
people would have said the same about
smoking maybe 100 years ago people would
have been like you don't smoke doctors
were prescribing
there was adverts saying more doctors
smoke camels than any other type of
cigarette because that was some sort of
like accolade for why you should smoke
camels
probably probably right because when it
was first introduced it was cool it was
cool wasn't it was chewing tobacco
I can i stuff so yeah no got no father
yeah but completely it's the only joke
you have to just fade in I'll take it
the only thing are you getting bored of
having to suggest a fight now I don't
need to justify anymore I think people
everyone that you're in contact with now
just knows everyone that is two things I
think I think it's been three years now
so I've gone from 23 to 26 yep
so when you mention that you don't drink
to 26 year old they get it mmm when you
do to 23 year olds they get it a bit
less yeah yeah
that's so so interesting that there is a
line and it is it is around that time as
well certainly between the age of 23 I
don't think that a exponential growth in
your own self understanding can occur
really before 22 23 I just this seems to
be a moment they a days they certainly
you don't know yourself yeah yeah
however for some people it's that you
see people that are 40 and 50 years old
who still haven't gone through that but
yeah it's it's so interesting that there
is the peers to be a big fat the middle
distribution of people who maybe didn't
understand and now do yep in the space
of 300 so when I first my first day I
was people saying I want were you so
boring why you know now it's like which
I could yeah and that changes like is
lit she like free words which I could
hmm and that's when you know you're on
the right track and like you I hear that
over and over again I meet somebody new
mmm who is probably sure to do so about
twenty five-plus though once once we've
once we finish I'm gonna take you
through a couple of things that were
working on at the moment for now some of
the listeners may know that we've got
some things going on behind the scenes
but I wrote the equivalent of a
manifesto between Christmas and New Year
which is a sobriety manifesto was three
thousand eight hundred words and I did
the entire thing on my phone while I was
watching Christmas films yeah like my
thumbs were wrecked
so it's just RSI today's wrote the whole
thing on my phone and they were talking
about so many of things that we've
brought up the fact that if I don't
drink I'm gonna miss out on social
engagements what would you say what I
want to hear what you would say if
someone was like oh if I don't drink I'm
worried that I'm gonna feel like an
outcast around my friends when they're
out on a night out or maybe they'll stop
inviting me to things or maybe I just
won't go what would you say to that I'd
say take a situation
okay take probably one of the most the
top the top social occasions that we
have probably have been our our age
weddings okay
weddings are renowned for drunk
drunkenness from family from people
imagine going even the dogs drunk when
the dogs from cut wedding well you know
take a situation where you can drive to
the wedding yeah see not you're not in a
situation where you can last minute like
ready last minute times he turns up and
taxis lay or whatever you don't have to
get that awful minibus back 45 minutes
from wherever in the sticks it's been
who in a mine you're in complete control
the whole time okay
you get there you turn up it's very
awkward because it's very different
people from different backgrounds so
everyone's in the same situation not
many people know it know many people the
wedding you probably know five or six
people you know and you'll go and meet
people throughout the night so that's
why weddings tend to have that kind of
collective you know always it's a
bonding it's a bonding process right
yeah yes because we only cook yeah I
know many people here yeah we're in it
and that that always kind of snowballs
and you end up hearing horror stories
that people getting drunk and
embarrassing yeah I went to a wedding
previously where someone was so drunk
that they thought they saw that the the
groom women of a girl on the day of the
wedding in the toilet and he and he
brought out to public and it caused the
whole issue and his girlfriend was fight
like all things always go wrong weren't
wrong it right in why do you want to be
involved yeah you know being sober you
can go there and you're in terms you can
enjoy you can have good food you can
have good good experience you can dance
a little bit and then when it's ready to
go because
they're always at a time when you need
to go you know as much people say I want
to stay one more drink yeah there's
always a time when you need to go you
get in T car and you leave mmm and you
wake up the next day and just look at
yourself and said I did enjoy that I
enjoyed that I had a good time I enjoyed
seeing it I enjoyed it been sharing a
special day with somebody I can remember
it I can remember it you know what I'm
gonna go for a go to the gym now yep
so I thought you totally right you
totally totally right about that there's
a number of things that I wrote in the
in this particular manifesto that that
kind of trigger off the back of that
I've worked somewhere in the region of a
thousand club nights across my career
and I can tell everybody that is
listening that nothing worthwhile
happens after 1:00 in the morning no
like me is the the absolute worst of
human behavior manifest like fights and
club kissing like no one really wants to
be a part of either of those things even
if you're enjoying the club kissing at
the time you cringe about the next day
then when it comes to the social
engagements thing I think what happens a
lot is if you're drinking especially
heavily you'll be less picky about your
social engagements yeah because you know
that if you've got [ __ ] or boring
friends or you've got to go to some
party that you probably don't want to go
to anyway kinda doesn't really matter
because you can just sedate the boredom
by getting lashed yep are you like okay
so hang on what you're saying is all the
awkwardness as well and the yeah and all
of those sort of things downstream from
the awkwardness or what's referred to as
approach anxiety and pickup artistry for
both men and women if the only way that
you can go up and speak to someone at
wedding is once you've had a drink
you have never cultivated the capacity
to actually go up and speak to somebody
yeah
you've out sourced it to this exogenous
version of courage which is alcohol and
it's so you are so so many so much
better learning that skill then rely on
alcohol because going sober that's one
thing you do learn you learn to have the
self confidence in yourself and that you
hold yourself in a higher safe esteem to
be able to approach someone and have a
conversation with them and like people
are trying to buy that you know the
whole quick-fix lifestyle alcohol is a
quick fix in my situation
you could take a step back invest in
yourself grow your confidence and then
be able to hold yourself in any social
occasion that goes back to what you said
about your coping with stresses from
work mmm
where you like I've had a hard day I'm
running this business that's essentially
like me holding on to a hundred mile an
hour speed train like just with one arm
on the final like the final thing at the
very end like desperately trying to like
them flapping around in the wind and
you're one of your coping mechanisms was
to use alcohol but that means that you
can't cope yep
like as a byproduct of that if you take
the alcohol away so it is a question
that probably a lot of people are
thinking I don't think we got into it
last time what was coping with stressful
situations like the first few times that
you that you weren't drinking when you
were no longer able to sedate yourself
on that you know you had everyone you
know the feelings that existed the
feelings that existed so I was still
feeling bad and stressful and I had that
emotions inside me so I had to do
something about it so what I did was I
turned to another attention something
else so I I focus my energy at first on
food so I'd have like a really Moorish
meal hmm just to forget about like to
take you sup my face oh you've switched
the coping mechanism from one to another
yeah uh odd odd it's better they forget
about it hmm anything goes anything
which kind of gave me that escapism
they're almost right anything to give me
that sense of escaping yeah I'll kados
it in one way because you blabbered
sleeping the another time because you
just forgetting you go away yeah and
food does it because you kind of you
know completely focus fixated on Moorish
food and then you kind of do fill up
afterwards because you just put crap
inside yeah but you know it's short-term
and yeah and you are tired and go to
sleep so it was taking that feeling that
emotion and protest in a different way
mm-hmm and then there must have been a
point in which you transition from that
to it not actually you're not needing to
use any of those mechanisms and you
actually being able to yes it with the
emotion so so it's simple simple simple
cognitive behavioral therapy to take the
the action-reaction stimulus response
the stimulus would stress the
responsible fit okay so now you get
seamless response the food was bad at
first it was you know it was pizzas and
burgers mm-hmm then just to interject
there for people who are looking at you
now
they wouldn't know that you were fat
tonight years ago real fur proper fat
proper fat yeah yeah so jiggle if you go
downstairs for now you look fantastic
like you've got the perfect runners
build which is good because that's what
you do yeah
so they I just swapped that two tons of
food and tons of healthy food mm-hmm so
I have like four salmon filets with like
like [ __ ] loads of food yeah and then
obviously over time you can manage that
down and portion it down and bring it
down so I got the point where if I was
having a bad day I didn't want to eat
someone broccoli but idle it should be
my stimulus-response [ __ ] they feel crap
certain broccoli fantastic you imagine
how many people would say is I had a bit
of dependency and alcohol for a while
young age and then I discovered salmon
and broccoli sweet oh yeah man like you
know I believe and we come at this from
two different angles and I'm now six
months into eighteen so why 18 because
I'd completed six without any challenge
mm-hmm I'd done six through wintertime
all of my all my students of sobriety
have almost been the same period which
has been just after Halloween yeah until
around about May time yeah and I know
that the most challenging period for me
is going to be through summer I don't
know whether you still get this but for
me in a beer garden British summer 6:00
p.m. sun's low good music on and I just
think [ __ ] copper burg like it would
be it's jut there's nothing quite now
copper back to a copper bug blue yeah
which is which is kind of
cool they've only recently brought that
out but there's just something about
that where I was like that's I don't get
a cheese to drink yeah I'm not a big
drinker naturally but that's one time
and I was like right I want to see first
off a complete six months as a twelve
seems like a figure but 18 seems like a
[ __ ] so I'm gonna do a team and
by doing it I knew that I'd go through
two winters that would be a little bit
less difficult but one summer which
would be great off I feel like there is
a replacement for everything and like
for copper Berg's kombucha
in a British pub like as the Black Bull
or something in over the edge and be
like excuse me I see that you've got
copper Berg on the menu I wondered if
you have any kombucha because my
microbiome in my gut is saying to me by
the way have you heard that Lord of the
Rings are coming out of Warhammer it
gives you a feeling like I was like and
you know what
like kombucha has its fermented tea it
has like a little bit of so I'll call it
any sense as mentioned it's got its got
fermented tea in it so it doesn't is
triggers on some form of similar pathway
yeah yeah so it does it does feel very
refreshing
yes I mean my thing was of always a pint
after football yeah a football I always
wanted to have like a real pint
and it couldn't the the wrong quite
beers were crap so I just changed that
for sparkling water because the
fizziness is the same yeah I guess and
you get our sense of just chopping it
down
oh really I really hate sparkling more
money just tastes kombucha kombucha true
so I want to move on to some stuff to do
with social media I was talking to
Theo on the way up and
we were laughing about the fact I don't
know whether you saw recently but the
UFC maybe about three or four months ago
now their part were tweeting it was a
big announcement it might have been a
hundredth anniversary of something or
whatever they piled this huge tweet that
obviously spent a fair bit of time
building up to it
big fuck-off typo right in the middle of
it with a spelling error and there's no
speed at which you can get onto the
Internet to delete that tweet
yeah like quickly enough and it just
started getting retweeted and like 5k
10k retweets a big old fat tweet I want
you to know about you guys have got was
it six hundred million reach or
something like that yeah hundreds of
millions of reach online
yep that means like and as much as you
can have the things are prepped in
advance and there's a brand design and
an architecture and there's briefings
and this not any other at the end of the
day there's a person with a button who
has to press it you know I mean like all
of this funnels down to one person's
finger yeah and then they have to just
like prep they press it once and once
it's gone that's it like it's out into
the world and I just wanted to ask why
it feels like to have that kind of
Titanic responsibility not only for
yourself but the brands that are behind
you get nervous before like a big
campaign goes out or is that kind of
stopped now for you that man presses a
button and there's a typo in it like Dom
yeah mate I'm really sorry
no where's any platform where you got it
yes
so like Facebook Instagram you've got
controlling you edit and like we are as
dependent on Twitter anymore I don't do
much on Twitter okay so like I
historically it was a nightmare Mike
here is my office
yeah yeah but like now it's like Twitter
product to there like to edit so you get
like happens it's annoying we get around
it but with Twitter you've still got
well on my own personal when I tweet and
I could guess but I'm I think I'm just
devastated
I am I even more bothered about messing
it up yourself or for clients or is it
equal I don't do I don't I don't run the
client so it's hard for me to like well
if you see someone who's a
representative yeah it's like it's just
that feeling of like bollocks
no I in them situations almost like no
one's to blame because it's um it's
everyone makes mistakes yeah it didn't
mean to only put one F in effective yeah
no one ever meant to do that like if it
was if it was like gross nebulous and
I'd be would like last different story
but yeah I mean I'm a situation where I
I I am really bad at spelling
I'm really bad I'm Dyslexic to like when
people make mistakes I completely
understand it because there's times when
I read back things I write mm-hmm it's
words omission
well I'm sure that word is some of the
sentences absent it makes no sense
moving forward what do you think is
going to happen with social majors as we
go on I don't know whether you listened
to the podcast that I did with Rory
Sutherland which was about the
psychology of advertising and I asked
him the same question over the next five
years do you think that people are going
to continue to give away their data for
free and their attention for free what
she thinks the future of the social
media in the attention economy as we
move forward now exactly you you are
competing on the attention okay and what
will cause the biggest shift is if
consumers realized the value of their
attention and their value at that time
and they start choosing to spend that
time wisely I think if you look at the
suite of products that exist at the
moment in that world you have
entertainment which is predominantly TV
you have gaming which is always growing
you have
friends and real-life interactions you
put in there as well and then you have
social media you know they're probably
the for protocol sport in there as well
as probably as a separate mm-hmm Fred
they're probably the five P places where
people spend their time it and then it
just the question is where do people
want to spend their time when you look
at some things like entertainment is
there is there a negative connotations
to set in that watching Netflix series
hmm
probably not you can probably do that
and you can feel good about yourself and
gaming probably again and probably more
evils in that get gaming but also some
politics coming out as well we've kind
of this skill that people are learning
as people about more and more time into
gaming social media has a lot of
negative connotations are they gonna be
opt Institute's that spend their time on
social media with the backlash ice bar
clashes are coming out now they will
probably be on social media but when you
take the emergence of a platform like
tick-tock I asked someone white what do
you like about a tick-tock and she said
and Hannah Hart you said it's the only
platform where no one is being arrogant
talking about themselves bragging and
it's just fun what's what's tick tock
tick tock yeah tick tock is there like
it's like an endless scroll video it's
like fine so I'm essentially but for
fullscreen okay really big 750 million
followers really big in China in the UK
really growing okay is it the thing
where people do memes to like singing
yeah that's what it was at first but
it's evolved now okay and it's it's got
no messaging it's got no and I'm like
pure IG TV yeah yeah and people that
should be nice on it okay so like people
like it's entertaining it's again it's
fun so it hasn't got the you people
updating them states it hasn't got any
more dev aspects yeah so people and I
feel people now are looking for their
time in more positive ways because we're
all starting to wake up to the point
that my attention is valuable and we're
all starting to understand that we have
only have time left so we have been more
wise about how we spend that time hence
why I think there's this middle part
about spending time with family friends
is growing because there's some key
traits which key things which are kind
of like I feel like the world's moving
back into connect
tippity in general so for the first time
in 24 years physical book sales
increased so people are now buying
physical books again okay because they
want that that feel that sound away from
screen
yep-yep-yep said that entire detector
dilations i've it's probably not reached
peak for all industries but it's kind of
reached a point where people enough that
the value connectivity in touching a
physicality again hmm so people are now
spending more time with their friends
and when you go out with your friends
now people are actually saying gaffur
yeah what do you think that means for
yourself obviously having to trigger on
these industries mmm-hmm it means that
as a business or personally as a
business as a business you know we we
are competing in the economy of an
attention economy so we have to play
where people are playing so in the
gaming space that's a growing market
when we do that can we grow a gaming
publishers can we work on in up in
gaming products and marketing
entertainment brands want to move into
the branded entertainment space can we
produce content which go straight to
Amazon Netflix where people can have a
piece of attention so for us you know we
we are a social first business but it
doesn't mean that operate in other areas
what we do is we take the insights and
knowledge from social which can mean
social media but social interactions and
social relationships and then that we
build a marketing company off the back
of that so that the social insights
could tell us how we need to do a home
campaign so it is where we're not
dependent on any platform not dependent
on any product but what we are depending
on it is the data that we collect from
social media because I'll inform things
moving forward do we do an experiential
campaign do we do a whatever campaign
yeah yep so the business model is is
solid it's very diverse
it's a cynical position and it's not
dependent on if Instagram switched up
tomorrow we'd still be here
yeah a Facebook turn awesome art would
appear mm-hmm might make it might make
the next couple of weeks a bit difficult
you'd be like probably worse with
clients knows yes
you can move between we can navigate we
can we can navigate we can look at new
areas we can new services so we're
looking at development obviously help
trial in the studio Palmerston yep you
know would you say podcasting is a
social product two years ago probably
not yes probably now it fits into that
space we're launching Brantly podcasters
but the clients pretty little thing that
podcast is unbelievable yep yep so we're
being reactive and moving to where the
growth in the market is so that's that
that's our mantra you know as long as
we're ever-changing and we keep in
brands at the forefront of what's
possible what we find and what's
possible can be anywhere social if you
are the someone who does social media
either as part of the small company or
potentially even it just as a consultant
on your own continuing to be adaptive is
going to be key over the next few years
yeah things I'd say I'd say also as well
probably take social media out your name
because a social media I think it'd put
people in the box you know what we're
talking to clients now about the racine
us business problems and how making you
social to solve them not as a social
media so it should like a wider wider
breadth of social to solve their
business problems you know not just
looking at when I think social media
manager I think schedule tweets that
person approach to the bun yeah when I
think social insights and social
strategy I think how can we use the
information from social media to
determine where this brands going to go
example example take KFC KFC have
probably been the best when it comes to
social media in the fast-food space they
their entire campaign to launch new
fries was driven through social so they
were doing social listening and see what
people say about their fries and there
was tons and tons of trees that people
saying that KFC of the worse price they
do or they did they did so obviously
that's socially insight there and a
conversation with people as informed
natural business change
they've gone okay off rise of crap it's
what people saying about them thirty
years ago if you sold but bad set of
fries someone no one will ever tell you
there's no feedback making no feedback
mechanism so people have actually been
looking at social media what people say
about KFC the
identified a problem and turned it into
a marketing campaign do you or how do
you categorize that then he totally
right is that is that using social
probably not with a social media agency
class itself as that also again probably
not because it's not to do with your
right I think social media I think about
the guy that schedules the the Facebook
postings I think the person that sat
behind ads manager yeah I don't think
about the person who is using the
inherent discourse and direct line of
communication between yourself and the
customer to inform more typical business
activities yep yep and that's what I
think bits big business now science
realizes that a social media is no
longer just a team of two people who run
the pages that's where your insights is
coming from thus where you can actually
understand your customer product your
future also bi-directional as well
exactly exactly
so there's only instances now I brands
are going straight to people in social
media take Qantas yesterday quant
two days ago a ten-year-old boy wrote
wrote a letter to the CEO saying that
he's just starting an airline Henry and
he's asked him for advice from the CEO
and co replied and he replied saying but
like a proper little letter saying this
is what you had a paper federal paper I
think signed you put on social media
that takes what 20 minutes at CEOs time
put on social media brand sentiment that
generates from you then look it up like
that is a nice thing to do I like you as
a brand yep that that the media love
they'll get from that we bigger than any
advertisement campaign they could go mmm
and that's from 20 minutes of time five
minutes at the social media managers
post it yep and it's out there do you
think that moving forward there is the
potential for well I know that this is
already the case but do you think that
customers and yourself need to be wary
about people triggering those mechanisms
in a manipulative fashion obviously it's
easy for someone to start faking those
kinds of situations yeah because it's we
know that this is the sort of thing that
will resonate with a life or its past
them
you know I've wearing to get mrs.
skeptical hat on here I'm like I'm
pretty sure we pitch that similar day
before about about that to work two
clients because it with what works on
social but I do a little deeper and you
know I'm probably in the top percentile
of people who will Skepta size around it
and because I understand social better
than most people and in some brands so
when I start hearing people thinking is
it's real its effect that's been uh
probably a bit concerned but it's the
most important thing now is to think
most important things our fantasy as a
brand are you authentically who you say
you are and if you're not people aren't
going to bind to you we did a piece of
research which said for the first time
ever brand values and brand causes which
they supported like social causes with
more important than price point so
actually the brought that brands us
about you is more important price people
pay more money if it means that buying
or seem to be buying from somewhere
which has a positive social impact and
then personalization so personalization
talking to people where they want to be
spoken to talking to people Harley once
we've spoken to so I'm an age now where
as a consumer I shop on my terms
you don't determine determines that we
shop on I'm not going to follow the full
of approach I don't want that people
don't want that anymore they don't they
they have so many abilities to purchase
here purchased their they'll decide
where they won't be purchased as a brand
you know just you have to not think of
you're in control and driving people
down the funnel you have to be able to
sweeten where they want to be spoken to
mmm-hmm so that's why you seen the rise
of loads of social commerce and of our
areas personally please take like to
think taking personal shoppers online
because everyone had a different way
they want to experience things and
that's what the brands that will win
with the ones that can cater wide rather
than narrow think about if you about one
point purchase a shop you're never going
to be allocated for everyone because not
everyone will pass that shop and people
will not go out that way to go to that
shop the whole days when we were when we
were kids and we were like I really want
to go to their trevor center doesn't
happen anymore okay they're not like
waking up soundtrap center I don't know
16:17 know spend the day walking around
their true do you think that um
a younger age bracket like the five or
the I guess the four to kind of 11 age
do you think that it's going to be
difficult to replicate that magic of
walking around somewhere like Toys R Us
or a large toy store there must be
something inherent that triggers on kids
okay so this this is what this is this
is mom one of my biggest I God Toys R Us
missed the opportunity to be the home of
toys okay they should have they could
have it on
they stayed as blockbuster but could
have been Netflix yeah they could have
turned it into experience yeah you go
there you play the toys you have games
you have played Asians everything like
IKEA like I care if they did that they'd
still be here
IKEA is basically Toys R Us for married
couples isn't it yeah yeah you know you
know you know you see it now in M&S M&S
are put in cafes and stuff into all
their shops because I know they
demographic wants to come and have a
coffee
alright and mine I go into there's an
MLS right next to me and it is a 2 p.m.
Wednesday afternoon rammed good
absolutely Ram you know you get
everyone's having salmon yeah you know
you get you getting good food you're
gonna have a couple of hours there
you're gonna pick up a read a book read
a book you know but they've catered to
their audience Toys R Us should have
pivoted and created an experience with
in their shop star those those that will
remain will facilitate experiences will
make it a place like the tiller bar
scene for example the bastings always
ahead because there's so many micro
trends you know you take dirty martini
how many girls and people do you see
with a picture over them and their
instruments and get your hair day yeah
how do people go there just because they
want a picture there yep you know it's
it's that it's that experience which
which physical stores still allow you to
have and again coming back to the point
of people go in turning and digital
aspect slightly if you can facilitate an
experience take IKEA you know you walk
around it he's still gonna purchase
something and the best example of this
come ATS what we say an earlier Harry
Potter land unbelievable you walk
through there and you literally frame
money out yeah I would I would have a
bit Bobby a straight away yeah that was
the first thing I did have you been to
the one in LA
no I've been to one in Florida oh well
I'm gonna guess there'll be soon I think
one in Florida was first and then the
one in but so the one in LA is a little
bit newer but man like it I was see
before we started you were like how old
were you when you went and I was like
hopping on about how much I liked it and
I was like I was 30 when I went and out
of the my inner 11 year old was just
losing it [ __ ] yeah but it was it was
fantastic like it was a new totally
right it was experiential and there is
until VR or AR gets to an ungodly degree
of fidelity you're not going to be able
to recreate that so yeah and again
[ __ ] shout-out club promoters like the
guys at dirty martini with the the halo
backdrop for anyone who doesn't know
what we're talking about the search
dirty martini on Instagram and you will
see thousands of girls and guys some
guys posing in front of this particular
backdrop and we've triggered off the
same so we saw that Dubai was using a
lot of flower walls fake yellow walls a
grand late we've got flower wall in our
club students again for every students
now got a 14 for Ana Buffalo or everyone
and that's the thing like if you if you
pay in that inks experience space you're
gonna have like you're gonna be
sustainable but you will find a way as
long as you're constantly constantly
innovating as well that what that
experience is so does that mean that if
you're a purely online business you and
you're not prepared to actually make
that move into the physical world you're
potentially going to start to run behind
a little bit here know again it
completely comes down to knowing your
audience so we're talking about dealing
with kids here with Tyros saying they
they want to play when we're looking at
something like a boohoo a pretty little
thing they understand what their
audience ones they want convenience they
want fast fashion you want outfits for
that with the weekend yep you know again
it comes back to the point we're saying
social allows you to understand your
audience and their behavior yeah you
know you need to ste to own that Lane
and stay in it so a brand which does
both horn buret okay
they're there their mantra is that they
want their people who work for them to
be experts of health well be they
actually are yeah they're really good
really can you tell me what's good for
joint health please
and then sure enough five minutes late
you know everything there is to know
about omega-3 acids and exactly so
they've got they've probably got a wide
range of customers they've catered very
well for one of my favorite jokes is
that Holland and Barrett have an ageing
audience an ageing customer which
obviously shows it's working yeah good
point very good point man that's that's
some that's some marketing jokes for you
right there yeah so but they're there
that that that method of understanding a
customer how you translate that online
to a 25 year old girl who's looking at
improving the hormones and getting
better balance mmm say my girlfriend was
ample how can she have that same
experience the hair or nails are exact
Skinner have that experience online but
she still gets in start and if then two
things can mirror each other to be able
to cater for everyone so is that would
that be the advent of things like live
chat live chat personalization what's up
I mean want some conversations with them
mm-hmm Instagram DMS all these areas we
can I've touched punch with people yeah
having conversations with you I tell you
what's hilarious so in between our last
our last podcast in this when I went to
LA last year and I was like man I need
to go and see one of these legal weed
dispensaries they are so it for anyone
who hasn't seen this if you can imagine
walking into an Apple store like we're
at the back there's a Genius Bar you go
in at the front you got to go through a
little bit security and there's a
security go in the door go go through a
little bit secure it but then you walk
in and there's iPads everywhere and
there's super futuristic looking things
and you can spring move a little event
to one side and smell the particular I'm
not like a weed connoisseur so I haven't
got a clue what I was on about and you
can go to the back and at the back
there's a group of like the geniuses and
you're like oh well sometimes I struggle
to sleep and I've got this pain in my
knee and then every so often the dog
annoys me and you know I guess so what
you need is our new sativa hybrid blend
with this this and this and you like I
just couldn't get away let you have a
see video on me all right all right
yesterday did you nice wave it around
yeah but it's you know that experience
you go you you know you think vape stars
make blows it up you run a bit there
got a guy over Tahoe and a beer like
yeah yeah yeah but you take that as a
premium aspect that the way you feel as
a customer going for that have you been
into one of my dispensary I've been to
one the means one in Vegas yeah the way
you walk through it the way they care
for you is of course so special it's
like this is what return needs to be
like and Quinn what's the point it's on
your terms
yep they they what and it's it's you are
you are the person in control no one's
trying to like and like Tesco's when
they they hide the bread at the end of
the the shops you've gotta walk forever
and thinking you know they're not
tricking your knowns
there's no tactics no tactics it's just
come on
so yeah I think that's that's that's the
key is that personalization of
conversation and personalization of
marketing in general and that's not just
putting your name on a coke can it's
which deepened that and the authenticity
of who you are as brand living up to who
you say you are it's where people will
win and I think I said when you take
that when you take that back to how
people connect
that's how you win as a person you're
authentically who you are you know
you're not two-faced you you have value
you live by them and your personal you
what you touched earlier on is super
correct and the podcast that actually
did with Theo and Eve for you guys on
social Minds triggered on a lot of this
which is what we refer to as social
equity and self branding the fact that
the I'm wearing a Nike SB t-shirt what
does that say or this says I can infer x
y&z about Chris due to that hashtag add
this is actually from the skates skater
Kody okay thank you very much Lincoln
code blah but that says this particular
thing about me yeah and you like okay we
move that forward to club nights one of
the most important things for us is
you've got a dirty martini
like what does that say about you okay
so here are the downstream implication
no one knows about that that's your
secret warhammer room
and then you know all of that all of
these different things and you told Iraq
I can 100% believe that brands values
and the causes that they support are
more important than price point now yeah
because everybody is searching
for some degree of meaning everybody is
held culpable and responsible due to
this always on communication and this
kind of serendipitous meeting that
happens by people being online and
seeing what you do seeing your purchase
history seeing what you watch like if
you've got a spot if I play like you can
hook your Spotify up to your Facebook so
that your Facebook displays what you've
most recently been listening to on
Spotify which means that almost your
music Tinder's off and your tinder
tinder they can link Spotify oh yeah oh
God so you can go on and be like people
so you tend I think these tinder and
tinge but you can yeah you can build out
what people listen to and so far as well
I don't think I would do very well on
tinder if I had a Spotify playlist on
there did some dodgy stuff but yeah like
you know dating for me it's all it's a
lot of metal like it's a lot Bring Me
The Horizon a lot of Architects because
I'm when I tend to be listening to music
I like to listen to and you know deep
which is my working podcast which is
unbelievable shout out to James grand
new is one of the best producers in the
world or I'm lifting heavy things and
running fast and that means I need some
angry music so those are the two ends
like the opposite end of the spectrum
I do the idea younger music for running
I feel of adventure scary yeah how are
you how are you getting on with you
running now because you were doing like
did the under Marvin yeah last year
how'd you find that tough you like you
are a long guy to run right like long
listens you body just like you realize
things like body that you never knew you
could happen to like you just get pains
places you know you could get Linda
marathon a full one phone yeah
you just got pains you can get paint you
get pains it was what was your worst
pain did you get any chafing no I was
polished not a bath Geoffrey ji I did I
did American high five years ago so I
knew I was gonna come so just like
Vaseline dope everywhere nice that was
fine it was a really real weird when
they're in the kind of car that I've
looked to where that comes in yeah hate
like my shoulder yeah that's bizarre
from supporting yourself alone yeah just
running running pop IT band went yeah
sorry yeah but a bear is funtastic
experience and to do London Marathon
it's like subways a bucket list so
yeah I love that and I think it was one
of the things which really pushed me and
I did it and I know I could do it so now
I'm like in a real place where I can I'm
looking for the next challenge but the
problem is like whatever the next
challenge is I want it to be bigger what
do you think were you thinking having
like a Half Ironman at some point hmm
but it's gonna have to be bigger and
that comes with a massive training
requirement yeah and it comes of a
massive lifestyle shift so I'm taking a
bit of like a year out just to retreat
reset body build some kind of
fundamental issues I've gone with my
body in terms of like I've got my left
leg be on the right leg so when I run a
little bit skew hence the IT band carry
my Flex whatever even bit more strength
and stability and have a better
foundation say okay what don't want to
go doing that really properly building
yeah yes 0.0 and I'm like I'm I am
anything I do next I am the way I am I
want to get bigger yeah that's like just
you think CEO Oh a big company
immediately think he probably races fast
cars semi professionally on a weekend he
does Iron Man's like he's probably like
a free climbing rock climber it just
appears to be this thing where people at
the top of the tree they have a
particular like a mindset that has
hunger attached to it and one of the one
of the byproducts of that is that I
don't think that you can switch it off
necessarily and it would appear that now
that you've removed alcohol and you've
really you've got this extra 20 to 30
hours a week
mm-hmm where you're not either drinking
or hungover you like oh god I really
need to do something because even what's
hilarious was if alcohol was a sport
you'd have probably been like these
national yeah I've even taken alcohol to
the extra how is the best at drinking
number one drinker so yeah like you know
industry yeah you don't absolute
extremist approach to things yeah
its characteristic it's yeah isn't is
the reason why I again I'm about to head
over can go back to alcohol mmm because
I I'm extreme I will I
that's why I'm so fortunate I could give
up yeah I am so fortunate my body says I
said to myself alright I'm gonna drink
anymore it was done yeah you know in you
know fine print there's a bit more but
yeah it was a case of I'm gonna charge
myself now I'm gonna do it I spoke to
Mike cause you about this and I said um
one of the things that I think about
people who hit rock bottom or some
degree close to rock bottom ie they have
a sufficiently traumatic experience that
springboards them back out of it is that
you are given a degree of motivation due
to the pain that you've gone through
that does enable you to move forward
what I think is particularly malicious
and nefarious and subversive is for
people who are maybe a bottle of wine
every couple of nights during the week
and maybe a bottle one night on a
weekend kind of person because that is
the silent killer that people don't
really see it's there's no sufficiently
traumatic situation they've gone through
they're waking up with a fuzzy head
maybe there's some downstream longevity
problems it's a gradual decline it's
just my thousand cuts day by day you
never realize anything year by year you
know it's anything but slowly you are
slipping decade by decade yeah
definitely do so there was a study done
by The Lancet which I will link in the
show notes below which was done over a
million people 26 countries and it
looked at the negative consequences of
alcohol consumption on health and they
found that alcohol is an overall
mortality risk and the synopsis to the
whole study is there is no safe level of
alcohol consumption 0 there is no I'm
getting particular downstream benefits
from having red wine because of
something that comes through from the
grapes there is you're netting a
negative there is no I can have one beer
a week because wheat does whatever ever
napping a negative there is no safe
level of alcohol consumption and to
reframe the conversation people having
about alcohol is cool like if you want
to go out and drink that is fine but
have to concede that that drink is
either at the best keeping your life the
same length or making it shorter you
know every night out and every drink
that you have is bringing you closer to
death and that's a fact that is a fact
is not going to extend your life it may
keep it the same or bring it shorter any
like when that's the cost that I have to
pay am I prepared to pay you a drink
again yeah so will do I will do I
genuinely believe that anything taken to
an extreme anything done in excess it
can be an error for some people good
example was last year I pushed my
solitude to excess I created my version
of Carl Jung's Bollingen Tower which was
a deep work space for me to really
really sort of dig my heels into
breaking some habits that I wanted I've
developed a reading habit which I'm
super proud of I've developed like my
mindfulness has gone through the roof
which is fantastic I had to pay a price
for that and the price was moving beyond
Solitude towards something that touched
on loneliness and that was a price I had
to pay
most people say huh you know I be I
spent some time in my own doing deep
work like Cal Newport living life at the
moment sat in an office on his own
soundproof like this probably but I had
to pay a price for that and there is
when it comes to not drinking there are
certain experiences that I want to have
and one of those includes drinking
however I can genuinely see each time
that I've gone sober and gone back to
drinking the window of drinking has got
shorter so first I did six months
sobriety then six months of drinking
then the second time I did it I did six
months of sobriety and three months of
drinking but within that time I only
went out four times so that was four
nights out and now this time I can see
I'll do it I'll probably touch base with
it again yeah and be like okay this is
how it feels this is what it means yeah
it may be once it may be twice and I can
see that being kind of the way that it
goes yeah and I can come back to the
point where I don't out at the weekend
it's still I'm still feeling it now
yeah hey after 18 months not drinking
yeah still didn't drink no after 18
months you're not drinking uh first
night out I'm gonna kill me that's when
we're going to the next podcast
fantastic the next day today we're gonna
sit here it's no question just gonna lay
my head on the microphone like this
that's a good point man that's when
we'll do it cuz you know is the same
cheering I fought in the first once that
was kind of like hard holding on some
things some experiences yeah and I think
is the next six months which are
probably the most interesting for you to
go through I mean I went to that now so
this is nearly bands especially summer
nearly month seven so I'm going away I'm
going away a lot this year got a lot of
things I want to do and you know I think
I hope that we increase to increase the
encouragement of people like your friend
that you met in the gym you know to
think still want to break free of this
rite of passage which bizarrely somehow
seems to have manifested itself in
society where everybody drinks and I
feel like I have to as well and you know
to take the cliches from the world that
we live in right now it's about taking
back control you know and haven't been
in complete control of you and yourself
and your actions all points wherever you
are but that's that that's the bizarre
thing again this is in the manifesto I
promise that I haven't shown it to DOM
before but he is he is almost quoting
directly from it and it shows that we've
all we both of us have come to the same
conclusions without having um actually
spoken about it and it was that what I
want to get through to people is that
drinking is not normality normality is
100 percent cognitive control maximum
efficiency total
total control of your personality your
actions and that drinking impedes that
the only reason that people see sobriety
as something which is so bizarre
is because it's uncommon yeah but if you
want to be at the close to the best in
your field you need to be uncommon
amongst uncommon men or women you got
your weird you do have to be weird and
thankfully we both are done man it's
it's been absolutely awesome I'm gonna
navigate these microphones yeah thank
you we will do number we will do number
three ladies and gentlemen make sure
that you press subscribe give us a like
DOM and his blog you still doing the
teetotal runner stuff not as much
anymore but I'll just do the Instagram
link will be in the show notes below
thank you very much
[Music]